mon ami de tv mag qui est à l'origine ce
sondage
c'est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque match on s'est parlé pendant la
danse brigade ya pas de danse et europa
ton corps pas de toi même mais c'est
vrai c'est génial cette attaque ne sais
pas encore
[Applaudissements]
bah écoute c'est bien parce que tu as eu
beaucoup de succès cette année
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
non merci des gens cesser les gens en
fait c'est fou moi j'aurais c'est ce que
j'ai dit je rap up j'aurais pas que les
manifs et noah discours de
regarder l'émission ça regardait depuis
tu le sais je la regardais
regardez j'ai regardé sur france 4 quand
je suis venu j'ai dit je vais rester
deux jours trois jours
avec vous et hélas les gens ils disent
que je suis le chroniqueur préféré donc
pas faire discours mais merci des
gencives ou fedouach le
[Rires]
plus grand silence
et hautement mais sans y apporter
beaucoup d'amoureux wallace non mais dis
donc et vous quelques chaussures je suis
heureuse je raconte mon
père qui fait
penser que je vais y aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu
as été élu ce soir
chroniqueurs préférés des français moi
je vais demander aux autres de laisser
raymondson meti boulin mais non
si si si c'est vraiment vraiment elle a
fermé ces dernières les autres sans
moment derrière désormais faible sur la
scène est très bien entendu merci mal à
rester là
non vraiment mon chéri
tu es aujourd'hui et non là franchement
ça me fait non mais ça me fait quelque
chose à moi aussi parce que c'est un
pari raymond la base un vraiment à la
base c'était mon pari et quand je les
appelais il m'a dit que ce que je viens
faire là
et je le dis pour l'instant
il a livré quelques fruits
très vite trouvé sa place dans
l'émission j'ai demandé qu'une seule
chose soit le raymond que je connais
dans la vie si tu veux vraiment que le
connaît dans la vie tu seras le rémo
exceptionnel qu'on voit aujourd'hui à
l'écran
[Musique]
des mots
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour toi
pour ta famille
je regarde bien dit je regarde qu'elle
raymond hains
aujourd'hui c'est
il ya eu deux tournants dans ta nou
le premier c'est ce soir je sais que tu
vas nullité vacances au camping des
flots bleus les chronos
lors à - 2 g dans l'eau mais
t'inquiète pas ça se passera
et puis
il ya eu cette consécration tu es le
chroniqueur d'année avec cinquante deux
pour cent des voix ares raymond tout le
monde
là sans rire vous je crois que c'est
très émue et tu le mérites pour moi je
voulais te dire je suis très très fier
de toi parce que tu as fait une année
formidable
et tu sais que je t'ai jamais lâcher
parce que on a eu des petits on peut
sans briller mais comme on s'embrouille
dans la vie mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de gens qui m'ont dit oui parfois
et on s'embrouille avec raymond mais
quand on s'embrouille avec raymond c'est
commencé quand on s'embrouille avec un
pote on n'en parle même pas le
la fin de l'émission et raymond il ya un
truc qui lui fait de la peine je vous
dis qui me qui me touche beaucoup c'est
que s'en fout quand on dit du mal de
nuit sur les réseaux mais quand on dit
du mal de moi et là qu'une envie c'est
de courir nu à mykonos
matière foot cyril vraiment et ça c'est
vrai
que si les gens bien et bravo à tous
parce que l'on fait ensemble en fait
l'émission laffan semble je peux pas
tout seul chez rien tout seul je parle
pas en premier c'est d'abord les autres
qui prennent des risques
et voilà c'est pareil a pas de mots
c'est c'est bien c'est celle là c'est
des [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
avec moi les prochaines heures accordé
ma chérie d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'était pour toute émission plaît
laissez-les pour l'instant c'est la star
non merci pour l'instant tout mis en
oeuvre et que tu profites de ce moment
et que tu ne supportes
ne rejoint pas les autres j'en ai fait
passer dans une autre catégorie
venir à côté de moi si tu veux mais la
panne